हेलो एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल तो सबसे पहले मुझे यह बता दीजिए सबको
मेरी आवाज आ रही है आईम
लाउड एंड
क्लियर ओके ओके वेरी गुड इवनिंग सलमान
वेरी गुड
इवनिंग वेरी गुड इवनिंग प्रणय
हेलो ओके थैंक यू एवरीवन थैंक यू थैंक यू
थैंक यू थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं बस तब तक
मे मशीने ऑन हो जाती हैं और हम डायरेक्टली
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन को रन करेंगे आज ओके आज
कोई भी पीपीटी नहीं
होगी और उसे सबसे पहले आपको एक इंपॉर्टेंट
चीज आपको मैं बता दूंगा जो हमने चेंजेज
किए
हैं शायद आप लोगों को ग्रुप में पता भी चल
गया होगा आपका कंफ्यूजन दूर करने के लिए
बट फिर भी हम आपको बता देंगे
बस मुझे दो मिनट का टाइम दीजिए तब तक
मशीने सारी ऑन हो जाएंगी और तब तक कुछ
स्टूडेंट्स और है जो जवाइन कर लेंगे आज की
क्लास में कोई न नया स्टूडेंट है जो
फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास में आ रहा
है जिसकी फर्स्ट क्लास
है गुड इवनिंग चंदन कुमार गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग आयुष फर्स्ट टाइम महादेव भगत
फर्स्ट
[संगीत]
टाइम कुमावत फर्स्ट टाइम
मुझे लगता दे लट ऑफ स्टूडेंट्स जो फर्स्ट
टाइम आए हमारी क्लास में कोई इशू नहीं कोई
इशू
नहीं
ओके एमस डीवी स्टार्ट नहीं हो रही शायद
कमांड गलत
होगी कोई नहीं अमित यह करोगे तो आपको और
भी मजा
आएगा बस मैं आपकी दो मिनट के लिए चैट नहीं
देख रहा हूं मशीन अभी तो थोड़ी सी अभी इट
विल टेक
टाइम
ओके मशीन इज वर्किंग नाउ
चलो देखिए थोड़े से चेंजेज किए हमने
जो फ्री एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्सेस जो आप पढ़
रहे हो जो मैं आपको पढ़ा रहा हूं
कंटीन्यूअसली डे वन से लेके डे 11 तक मैं
पढ़ा चुका हूं आपको तो कोर्स की क्वालिटी
सेम रहेगी इस कोर्स का नाम पहले था जो
डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल था बट दे आर लॉट
ऑफ कंफ्यूजन कि डीसी जेएसपी एक थ थोट कल
हो गया एक प्रैक्टिकल्स हो गया एक
डीसीएसपी तीनों के नाम में थोड़ा सा
कंफ्यूजन हो रहा था तो वह कंफ्यूजन दूर
करने के लिए हमने सिंपली इस कोर्स को क्या
किया है नाम चेंज किया है डी एच ई एच डे
फोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल इसका नाम रखा
है तो अभी जो भी इसके थंबनेल्स होंगे आपको
इसी के नाम से मिलेंगे डे फोनिक्स डे
फोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल्स और जो आपको
सिलेबस बताया था डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल्स
का सिलेबस सेम रहेगा सिलेबस में कोई भी
चेंजेज नहीं होंगे
क्वालिटी के साथ कोई भी कंप्रोमाइज नहीं
होगा क्वालिटी सेम रहेगी सब कुछ सेम रहेगा
मतलब कुछ भी नहीं बदलने वाला है सिलेबस
सेम क्वालिटी सेम इंस्ट्रक्टर सेम बस नाम
बदला है सर्टिफिकेट पर आपके डीसी जीएसपी
प्रैक्टिकल की जगह डीई एच ई रहेगा व डी डे
फोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल डीई एई रहेगा
और आपको बता देता हूं य डे फोनिक्स अकेडमी
है तो मैंने हमने आपको बताया था कि आपको
नोट्स चाहिए तो आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
गो टू अकेडमी चैनल और यहां पर हमने क्या
किया था एक जस्ट इट विल टेक टाइम यहां पर
भी नाम चेंज हो गया होगा पहले डीसी जेएसपी
प्रैक्टिकल आ रहा था आप अगर अब सर्च करोगे
यहां पर क्या है डीसी जेएसपी प्रैक्टिकल्स
नहीं आएगा यहां पर डीई एच ई आपको देखने को
मिलेगा
ओके यहां पर देखोगे तो आप यहां पर और भी
व्यू ऑल सब कैटेगरी में भी यहां पर आ गया
एड
मी वेट
वेट यह रहा आप क्या करोगे ज फ्री
रिसोर्सेस के अंदर क्लिक करोगे जैसे ही
क्लिक करोगे वहां पर आपको देखने को मिलेगा
सेम अभी यहां पर हमने क्या मेंशन किया है
डीई एई सर्टिफिकेट नोट्स एंड रिसोर्सेस
जस्ट सिंपली जो फर्स्ट टाइम आए हैं या जो
अपकमिंग क्लासेस में आने वाले हैं उनको
सिंपली क्या करना है जितने भी पीपीटी हम
पढ़ाते हैं या जो भी उ इससे रिलेटेड आपके
जो रिसोर्सेस रहेंगे यहां पर हम क्या
करेंगे ऐड करेंगे आपको जस्ट क्या करना है
यहां पर जस्ट गेट पे योर 0 दिस इज द लाइफ
टाइम एक्सेस आपको लाइफ टाइम एक्सेस रहेगा
यहां पर उन नोट्स के ऊपर और नोट्स को आप
पढ़ सकते हो यहां से आपको नोट्स बनाने की
जरूरत नहीं है दूसरी चीज क्या होगी थोड़े
टाइम के बाद हम क्या करेंगे जो जिन्होंने
क्या ₹ पे किए क्योंकि ₹ कोई बड़ी अमाउंट
नहीं है इसमें मैं अपने लिए नहीं कर रहा
आप लोगों के लिए कर रहा हूं क्यों नोट्स
क्या है कि मेरे नोट्स सेल आउट ना हो
इसलिए क्योंकि अपने मेरे हाई क्वालिटी
नोट्स हैं तो उनको कोई सेल ना करें इसलिए
मैंने इसको खुद से ही अपने जस्ट ₹ में रखा
हुआ है आपको सिंपली यहां पर जाना है परचेज
करना है जवाइन करना है रिसोर्सेस यहां पर
अवेलेबल मिलेंगे जैसे क्लास खत्म होती है
यहां पर आपको देखने को मिलेंगे दूसरी चीज
मैं आपको बता रहा था जैसे ही हम क्या है
कि कुछ टाइम के बाद स्विच करने वाले हैं
जैसे कि लाइव क्लासेस कंटीन्यूअसली चलेंगी
आपकी
जिनको
करके एक आर्टिकल लिख के आपको क्या करना है
डेफ अकैडमी और प्लस में मेरे को भी टैग
करना है और तीसरी चीज एक ये मेरा
[संगीत]
क्यूरी होंगी जो मुझे लगता है कि आपकी
बहुत अर्जेंट क्यूरी सॉल्व होनी चाहिए तो
यहां पर मुझसे पूछ सकते हो मैसेज करके
आपको हो सकता है 24 48 आवर्स के बाद उसका
रिप्लाई मिले बट आपको मिलेगा ओके आप इधर
भी रिक्वेस्ट भेज सकते हो मुझको फॉलो कर
सकते हो यहां पर भी आपको अपडेट
मिलेंगे क्लासेस से रिलेटेड और आपको लिंक
दिन पर भी अपडेट मिलेगी तो आप जहां पर भी
कंफर्टेबल हो वहां पर फॉलो कर सकते हो और
यहां से हम क्या कर टीम डेनिक्स को भी
फॉलो कर सकते हो ओके ये इंपोर्टेंट
इंफॉर्मेशन थी आप लोगों के
लिए सबको समझ में आ
गया ओके और यह और बता देता हूं डेफ का यह
रहा अभी आप सिंपली क्या करो जैसे सर्च
करोगे आपने डेफ अकेडमी दिस इ द डे फोनिक्स
साइबर सिक्योरिटी पेज आपको इसको भी फॉलो
कर लेना यहां पर भी इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन
जैसे कोई भी कोर्स आता है या अपकमिंग कोई
भी अनाउंसमेंट होने वाली है या कुछ जिनकी
जॉब लगी है या कुछ रिसोर्सेस यहां पर भी
प्रोवाइड किए जाते हैं आप हमेशा अपडेट
रहोगे हमारे साथ चौथी चीज क्या है कि आप
क्या कर सकते हो जो
[संगीत]
न्यू कमर के लिए जो फर्स्ट टाइम आए हैं और
जिनको पहले से पता था तो उनको ये
इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड करनी थी
हमने सर्टिफिकेशन का नाम बदला है डे
फोनिक्स डे फोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल्स
ओके तो दिस इज द इंपोर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन
शायद सबको समझ में आ गया किसी को कोई डाउट
नहीं होगा एक मिनट एवरीथिंग
कि कोई डाउट है अभी अभी मैं क्लास स्टार्ट
करने वाला हूं
बताइए फिर से क्लास को हम कंटिन्यू करते
हैं हां अगर आपने लास्ट क्लास नहीं देखी
है तो आज देख सकते हो लेकिन आपको मैं यही
बोलूंगा कि प्लीज क्लास को देखना
ओके हम क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी ओके
स्टार्ट करें एवरीवन प्लीज सभी रिप्लाई
कीजिए नहीं आपको बताया अन एक्सपेक्टेड मी
मैंने आपको बताया यह रहा जस्ट सिंपली आपको
क्या करना है यहां पर यह रहा डे फोनिक्स
यह रहा डेनिक्स आप सिंपली क्या करो देखो
आपको बता देता हूं नाउ गो बैक यह मेरा
google.com क्लिक करना है क्लिक करके आपको
क्या करना है गो टू अकेडमी टैब अकेडमी टैब
प जाओगे गो टू फ्री रिसोर्सेस गो टू दिस इ
दिस वन डीई एच सर्टिफिकेट नोट्स एंड
रिसोर्सेस सिंपली क्लिक करोगे यहां पर
आपको गेट द कोर्स क्लिक करना है यहां पर
फुल नेम मोबाइल नंबर ईमेल व्हाट एवर स्टेट
और उसके बाद आपको क्या करना इसको फिल करना
और अप्लाई करना और आपको एक्सेस मिल जाएगा
ओके अब सबको समझ में आ
गया अभी क्लियर है किसी कोई कंफ्यूजन है
अभी भी बताइए
अभी हम अपने क्वालिटी कंटेंट या जो कोर्स
कोभी स्टार्ट करने वाले
हैं और अभी लिंक आपको प्रोवाइड कर दिया
गया य आपको ट चैनल का यह रहा यहां पर
सिंपली क्लिक करो और आप क्या कर सकते हो व
चैनल को जवाइन कर लो वहां पर हमेशा आपको
अपडेशन मिलता है आयुष व्ट हैपन क्या हो
गया आप नो बोल रहे हो
मैट्रिक्स प्लॉट आपका ओरिजिनल नाम क्या है
बताइए और अभी मे टीम ऑनलाइन है वह आपको
देख लेंगे आपके नाम से कोई एंट्री हुई है
नहीं हुई है
ओके यस
ओके तो टीम आपको जवाब दे देगी अभी साथ के
साथ चेक करके और हम क्लास को स्टार्ट करते
हैं ना यह हमारा काली नक्स है जिसको हम
यूज करने वाले हैं आज की क्लास में और
लास्ट क्लास में मैंने आपको बताया था नेट
बायोस क्या होता है और एसएमबी क्या होता
है उसके बारे में इंट्रोडक्शन दिया था और
कुछ चीजें आपको फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
टास्क प्रोवाइड किए थे वो आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है उसको फाइंड आउट करना
क्योंकि अगर आप खुद से फाइंड आउट करोगे तो
आपको बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिलेगा इसलिए
मैंने आपको फाइंड आउट करने के लिए बोला था
लास्ट क्लास में थोड़ा सा प्रैक्टिकल किया
था हमने नेट वायस के बारे में कि
इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे गेट आउट करते हैं अभी
कंटिन्यू करेंगे वहीं से और आज कंटिन्यू
कंटिन्यू जो प्रैक्टिकल है एसएमबी
एन्यूमरेशन का उसको कंप्लीट कर देंगे मतलब
नेट बायोस और एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन आज हम
कंप्लीट कर देंगे अपनी क्लास के अंदर ओके
अभी के लिए मैं नेक्स्ट कुछ टाइम के लिए
जब आपकी चैट सेक्शन नहीं देखने वाला तो
अभी प्लीज कोई डाउट नहीं पूछेगा जब भी मैं
आपको बोलूं कि अभी आप अपना डाउट पूछिए तभी
आप मुझसे डाउट पूछना अदर वाइज क्या कि अभी
मैं आपकी चैट देखूंगा नहीं डाउट रिलेटेड
और वो स्किप हो जाएगी और बाद में बोलो सर
आपने मेरा डाउट क्लियर नहीं किया लेकिन
दूसरा तरीका ये है डाउट पूछने का अगर आप
क्या किसी कारण से आपका डाउट नहीं लिया
जाता यहां से आपको लगता है कि सर मेरा
वैलिड डाउट था तो आपको क्या करना है क्लास
एंड हो जाएगी स्ट्रीमिंग स्ट्रीम वीडियो
आपकी
youtube2 पर आपको क्या करना है कमेंट
सेक्शन में अपने अपना नाम लिखिए और नाम के
सामने डाउट करके आप पूछ लीजिए कि सर मेरा
ये डाउट था क्लास में आप नहीं बता पाए
आपने नहीं बताया तो प्लीज अभी क्लियर कर
दीजिए तो या तो उसी टाइम मैं आपका रिप्लाई
में क्लियर कर दूंगा या मैं नेक्स्ट क्लास
में आपका डाउट क्लियर कर दूंगा आई
प्रॉमिस चलो अभी हम स्टार्ट करते हैं मैं
अभी टर्मिनल को ओपन करता हूं ना
लास्ट क्लास में मैंने आपको एन मैप के
थ्रू नेट वायस एन्यूमरेशन करना सिखाया था
उसकी कुछ स्क्रिप्ट आपको बताई थी ओके और
एक टूल बताया था एनएमबी लुकअप के बारे में
अभी मैं एक बार जूम कर देता हूं
इसको सबको क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा है
एवरीवन फंट साइज वैलिड है सबके
लिए
ओके अभी मैं पिंग करके देख लेता हूं मेरा
टारगेट अभी क्या है मेरा विंडोज सर्वर है
मेरे मशीन में जो मेरे पास जो नेटवर्क है
जिसके ऊपर मैं अभी क्या करने वाला हूं
टेस्टिंग करने वाला हूं मेरा टारगेट कौन
सा है एक विंडो सर्वर जिसका आईपी एड्रेस
192.1
168.0 222 ये अभी मैं इसको पिंग कर लेता
हूं तो सक्सेसफुली मेरा पिंग हो रहा है
मतलब मेरी मशीन एक्टिव है लाइव है ओके
मैंने चेक कर लिया यह मेरा टारगेट रहेगा
तो मैंने लास्ट क्लास में आपको बताया था
मेन अगर मैं आपको बताता एनएमबी लुकअप के
बारे में क्या क्या करती है नेट बायस ओवर
टीसीपी आईपी एक नेट बायस ओवर टीसीपी आईपी
क्लाइंट यूज टू लुक अप नेट वायस नेम्स ओके
तो ये ऐसा टूल्स है इसको हम यूज करते हैं
यूज किया था लास्ट क्लास में नेट वायस ककप
इज यूज टू किरी क्यूरी नेट बायस नेम्स एंड
मैप देम टू आईपी एड्रेसस इन ए नेटवर्क
यूजिंग नेट बायोस ओवर टीसीपीआईपी क्यूरीज
मैंने आपको क्या बताया था कि आजकल नेट
बायस क्या है कि कम यूज किया जाता है
देखने को मिल जाएगा लेकिन पहले इसका
ज्यादा यूज किया जाता है क्या करता है
आपका यह नेम रेजोल्यूशन करता है किसका
आपके कंप्यूटर नेम का ओके तो उसी चीज को य
क्या करता है उसी इंफॉर्मेशन को क्यूरी
करता है नेट वाय प्रोटोकॉल के थ्रू यह टूल
और आप आपको आपकी स्क्रीन के सामने रिजल्ट
शो करता है अगर नेट वायस उसके अंदर इनेबल
है तो ओके तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं इसको
क्वाइट कर देते हैं एक बार नाउ तो मैंने
आपको बताया था कुछ कोड बताए थे 003 आपको
मैंने बताए थे और 00 जैसे कि अभी मैं
कमांड को एम भी लुक अप मैं देखो इस तरीके
से एंटर तो मैंने आपको बताया था यह क्या
है होस्ट नेम या वर्क स्टेशन सर्विस जीरो
जीरो कोड है और एक्टिव है यह मैंने आपको
बताया था यहां पर क्या अभी खाली है कहीं
यहां पर यूनिक देखने को मिलेगा अभी यहां
पर ग्रुप आपको देखने को मिल रहा है तो
इसके भी तीन कोड मैंने आपको बताए थे 00 1
सी और ई व सी क्या होता है डोमेन कंट्रोलर
फॉर ए डोमेन जो भी नाम मिलेगा अभी यहां पर
क्या आ ये वर्क स्टेशन सर्वर मतलब ये आपके
वर्क ग्रुप जो भी ग्रुप है वर्क स्टेशन के
ऊपर उसका नाम बता रहा है यहां पर उसके बाद
ये है वेगें 2008 आ2 यह भी क्या है ट मतलब
क्या है आपका फाइल सर्वर नेम है ये फाइल स
सर्विस है उसका होस्ट रिकॉर्ड है उसका
यहां पर ये नेम शो कर रहा है ओके तो इससे
रिलेटेड भी मैंने आपको टास्क बताया था
फाइंड आउट करने के
लिए अभी हम अभी हम नेक्स्ट टूल पर शिफ्ट
करेंगे नेक्स्ट टूल क्या है कि एक एनबीटी
स्कैन होता है अगर आपको अगर आपकी मशीन में
इंस्टॉल है नहीं तो हम क्या कर उसकी कमांड
होती है एटी
इंस्टॉल एनबीटी स्कन नेट बायो स्कन ओके
एनबीटी स्कन हिट एंटर अब ये क्या इंस्टॉल
कर देगा ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल्ड है तो अभी हम
इसको क्या करते हैं हेल्प फाइल चेक करते
हैं हेल्प फाइल चेक करते हैं एनबीटी स्कैन
की हान हान हेल्प ओके हान हान हेल्प ये
इसकी हेल्प फाइल आपके सामने अब ये क्या
काम करता है एनबीटी स्कैन वर्जन
1.7.2 है दिस इज अ फ्री सॉफ्टवेयर इट कम्स
विद एब्सलूट नो वारंटी यू कैन यूज
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर टर्म्स ऑफ जी एनय जीपीएल
2.0 व्ट एवर ये इसके यूसेज का तरीका है
जिसमें हाइन व वर्बोस हाइन डी डम पैकेट
हाइन ई हाइन एल हाइन डी हाइन यूज लोकल
पोर्ट 137 फ स्कंस मुझे यह बताइए 137
पोर्ट किसके लिए था
बताइए कोई भी बताएगा 137 पोर्ट किसके लिए
यूज किया जाता है
नहीं आप ट्राई नहीं कर
सकते नॉट
अलाउड बताइए 1 37 पोर्ट किस चीज का था
बताइए
बताइए अभी टूल के बारे में बताता हूं कि
टूल यह एक क्या है ऑटोमेटिक आईपी नेटवर्क
स्कैनिंग टूल है जो क्या करता है आपके नेट
बायस इंफॉर्मेशन को या आईपी को नेट बायस
इंफॉर्मेशन में कन्वर्ट करता है ओके तो
टूल को मैं आपको यूज करके दिखाता हूं कैसे
यूज कर सकते हैं इसको क्लियर कर देते हैं
तो यह है आपका टूल
एनबीटी स्कन उसके बाद आईपी एड्रेस
192.168 222 यह मेरा टारगेट है देन सिंपली
मैं क्या करता हूं अभी व ब दे देता हूं
ताकि मुझे पता रहे किय टूल किस तरीके से
काम कर रहा है
ओके नवी
हिट एंटर देखिए डूइंग एनबीटी नेम स्कैन
फॉर एड्रेस फ्रॉम सोन सो टेबल यह देखिए
सेम इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा है
अभी देखिए यहां पर सेम वही इंफॉर्मेशन है
जो लास्ट कमांड में हमने देखा था यह इसका
मैक एड्रेस है और यह देखो यूनिक लिख के आ
गया अभी ग्रुप लिख के आ गया और जो टेबल
मैं आपको बताई थी अगर आप चाहो तो इसकी
हेल्प फाइल देखी होगी आपने तो एक ऑप्शन
होता है एनबीटी
स्कैन हाइन व वर्बोस हाइन आर r मतलब पोर्ट
137 को यूज करेगा ये और देन उसके बाद आईपी
एड्रेस
192.168 222 हिट एंटर
देखिए सेम इंफॉर्मेशन है कुछ अलग से तो है
नहीं अगर एक और टारगेट है मेरा जो
181 ऐसे डायरेक्टली चेक करते हैं 181 क्या
इस पे काम करेगा नहीं इसके लिए भी काम
नहीं कर ओनली विंडोज के लिए काम कर रहा है
तो यह था आपका नेट बायस एन्यूमरेशन के जो
टूल्स मैं आपको बता रहा था एक और है
एनबीटी का हम यूज करते हैं एनबी स्टेट
नेटवर्क नेट बायो स्टैटिक्स एक टूल होता
है जो इनबिल्ट यूटिलिटी होती है आपकी जो
विंडोज के अंदर होती है तो उसको हम कब यूज
करेंगे जब हम एन्यूमरेशन करेंगे आफ्टर
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन तब हम उसको यूज
करेंगे वैसे चाहो तो आप अभी भी यूज कर
सकते हो लेकिन क्या है वो क्या है कि
विंडो के ऊपर ही आपको यूज करना होगा
लिनक्स के ऊपर नहीं विंडो के ऊपर तो जब हम
क्या कर लेंगे एक बार एक्सप्लोइटेशन
कंप्लीट कर लेंगे एक्सेस गेन कर लेंगे
सिस्टम के अंदर तब हम फिर भी नमरे करते
हैं उस केस में हम क्या करेंगे उस टूल को
यूज करेंगे जिसका नाम है एनबीटी स्टेट
मतलब नेट बायोस्टेट ओके उस टूल की अगर
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोवाइड करूं ये रहा एक
मिनट ओके दिस
वन नाउ दिस वन दिस वन दिस इज द टू ये रहा
ये तो एनएमबी लुकअप है ओके य एलम बी लुकअप
है तो वो अलग टूल्स भी उसके बारे में
मैंने विंडोज की यूटिलिटी है मैं आपको बता
दूंगा अभी हम चलते हैं अपने एसएमबी
एन्यूमरेशन पे ओके अभी हम करेंगे एसएमबी
एन्यूमरेशन तो आपको पता है मेरी टारगेट
कौन सी है विंडोज मशीन है
क्लियर ओके तो अभी मैं क्या करता हूं
मैंने सिंपली अभी रन करना ए मैप ए मैप
उसके बाद एक बार आपको दिखा देता हूं
कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस रनिंग है आपको याद हो
गई होंगी सर्विस वर्जन चेक करने देखिए
सर्विस स्कैन उसके बाद
हाइन यह रहा देन उसके बाद मैं क्या कर
सकता हूं एक बार डायरेक्टली मैं रन कर
देता हूं एक बार डायरेक्टली टारगेट
192.168 222 और उसके बाद हान t4 ये रहा
आयो साब हमारी वेबसाइट पर नहीं ट्राई कर
सकते हमने आपको ऑथराइजेशन नहीं दिया
है ओके तो देखो य सर्विसेस
अवेलेबल 21 22 से मुझे अभी कोई मतलब नहीं
80 से मुझे कोई मतलब नहीं 5 139 445 ये र
नेट बाय सर्विसेस आर रनिंग और ऊपर से क्या
है 445 445 क्या है एसएमबी मतलब जो मेरी
मशीन है जो विंडोज मशीन है जो टारगेट मशीन
है उसके ऊपर कौन सा पोर्ट ओपन है 445 445
किसका पोर्ट नंबर है आपका एसएमबी का अभी
एजेक्ट इसका वर्जन भी नहीं है मेरे पास
इसका वर्जन फाइंड आउट करने के लिए एसवी
सर्विस वर्जन स्कैन करते हैं हम इसको
देखिए अभी सर्विस वर्जन स्कैन और करते हैं
इसके ऊपर हमें पता चल जाएगा और भी ज्यादा
डिटेल्स में
50 पर
डन सबको समझ में आ रहा है ना कि चल क्या
रहा है एवरीवन
अभी तक 50 स्टूडेंट्स थे और छोड़ के जा
चुके
हैं यह अच्छी चीज नहीं है
बस कंप्लीट हो गई स्कैनिंग
हमारी नाउ अभी हम चेक करते हैं ये देखिए
यहां पर हमें पता चल गया 135 माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
विंडोज आरपीसी 39
[संगीत]
प्रोटोकॉल्स ओके ट एंटर यह देखिए यह
एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल कैटेगरी सेफ
डिस्कवरी अटम टू लिस्ट द स्पोर्टेड
प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड डायलग ऑफ एसएमबी सर्वर
बेसिकली यह फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करती
है कि एसएमबी का कौन सा प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन
यूज किया जा रहा है वर्जन वन वर्जन टू
वर्जन थ्री वर्जन 3.1 व्हाट एवर ओके तो अब
इसका हम यूज करने वाले हैं तो हम इसका यूज
करेंगे ए
मैप हान अभी मेरा पोर्ट फिक्स है 445 को
यूज करना है मुझे 445 देन उसके बाद हाइन
हान स्क्रिप्ट हाईफा स्क्रिप्ट देन एस
एमबी प्रोटोकॉल्स एसएमबी पी आर ओ टी ओ सीओ
प्रोटोकॉल्स देन उसके बाद टारगेट आईपीआई
192.168 व नहीं नहीं
0.22 ट एंटर देखिए
अभी इसने क्या रिजल्ट दिया आपके सामने 445
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट डीएस स्कप देखो एसएमबी
प्रोटोकॉल्स यह कौन सा बता रहा है एनटी एल
एम 0 एसएमबी वर्जन वन ओके डेंजरस बट
डिफॉल्ट मतलब आपको यह बता रहा है य खुद ही
बता रहा है कि एसएमबी वर्जन न वर्जन वन का
होना एक तो खतरनाक है दूसरा क्या है
डिफॉल्ट कॉन्फिन को य यूज कर रहा है मतलब
जो कॉन्फिन थी उन्हीं को यूज कर रहा है
उसकी कॉन्फिन को कभी चेंज नहीं किया गया
जब इसको कंफिल किया होगा तो अभी हमें पता
चल गया कौन सा वर्जन यूज हो रहा है अभी
मुझे एक और स्क्रिप्ट होती है और वो
स्क्रिप्ट कौन सी होती है ए मैप हाइन प
445 देन उसके बाद हाइन हाइन स्क्रिप्ट हान
स्क्रिप्ट देन उसके
बाद एसएमबी हाइन
सिक्योरिटी हाइ फन सिक्योरिटी हाइ फन मोड
हाइ फन मोड अब इसके बारे में अगर आपको
डिटेल देखनी है
192.168 222 हिट एंटर यह
देखिए ये आपको क्या बता रहा देखो अब य
स्क्रिप्ट करते क्या है मैं आपको एक काम
कर देता हूं एक नया टर्मिनल ओपन करता हूं
न न्य टब नहीं चाहिए
मुझे एक नया टर्मिनल
चाहिए न्यू विंडो ओके अभी विंडो को मैं
क्या करता जूम कर देता
हूं ओके और अभी इसको हम क्या कर देंगे
छोटा कर देंगे
[संगीत]
ओके ना य
हमारी अभी य क्या हो गया इसको भी हम जूम
कर
देंगे यह रहा सबको य क्लियर दिखाई दे रहा
है और दूसरी विंडो
आपकी य अब इसको मैं क्या करता हूं अभी
इसको ट यर बना लेता हूं एक बार ना अभी हम
चेक करते हैं एप हान आन
हाइ फन हेल्प इसका नाम क्या था हमारा
एसएमबी हाइन सिक्योरिटी
मोड यह देखिए अब यह क्या करता है देखि
बहुत कुछ लेगा इसमें सिक्योरिटी मोड हाउ
टू इंटर यूजर लेवल ऑथेंटिकेशन यूजर लेवल
थट क्या च यूजर सेपरेट यूजर नेम पासवर्ड
दैट इज यूज टू लॉग इन टू द सिस्टम दिस इज
द डिफॉल्ट सेटअप ऑफ प्रेटी मच एवरीथिंग
दीज डेज शेयर लेवल ऑथेंटिकेशन द एनोनिमस
अकाउंट शुड बी यूज टू लॉग इन एंड देन
पासवर्ड इज गिवन इन प्लेन टेक्स्ट व्हेन ए
शेयर इज एक्सेस्ड तो ऑल यूजर्स हु हैव
एक्सेस टू द शेयर यूज दिस पासवर्ड दिस वाज
द ओरिजिनल वे ऑफ डूइंग थिंग्स बट इज नॉट
कॉमनली सीन नाउ इफ ए
सर्वर यूज शेयर लेवल सिक्योरिटी इट इज
वल्नरेबल टू स्निफिंग ओके देखिए अभी यह
कौन सी सिक्योरिटी कर से लेवल यहां पर है
नहीं ऑथेंटिकेशन लेवल यह बता रहा उसके बाद
नाउ चैलेंज रिस्पांस पासवर्ड सपोर्टेड दे
लॉट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन मैसेज साइनिंग तो इसको
आप खछ तो दिस स्क्रिप्ट विल अलाउ यू टू
यूज कोड एसएमबी कोड सन सो आर्गुमेंट टू
यूजर नेम पासवर्ड मतलब आपको बेसिकली बता
रहा है अब यहां पर हमें क्या मिला है
एसएमपी सिक्योरिटी मोड अकाउंट यूज गेस्ट
अकाउंट ऑथेंटिकेशन ल यूजर चैलेंज रिस्पांस
सपोर्टेड मैसेज साइनिंग डिसेबल्ड ओके
मैसेज साइनिंग डिसेबल्ड अगर इसको चेक
करोगे आप यह क्या काम करता है मैसेज
साइनिंग इफ रिक्वायर्ड ऑल मैसेज बिटवीन द
क्लाइंट एंड सर्वर मस्ट बी साइंड बाय ए
शेयर
की ड्राइड फ्रॉम द पासवर्ड एंड द सर्वर
चैलेंज इफ सपोर्टेड एंड नॉट रिक्वायर्ड
मैच साइनिंग इज नेगोशिएट बिटवीन क्लाइंट्स
एंड सर्वर्स एंड यूज्ड इफ बोथ स्पोट एंड
रिक्वेस्ट इट बाय डिफॉल्ट विंडोज क्लाइंट
डज नॉट साइन मैसेजेस सो इफ मैसेज साइनिंग
इज नॉट रिक्वायर्ड बाय द सर्वर तो मैसेज
प्रोबेबली वुड नॉट बी साइन ए मतलब बेसिकली
अटैक हो सकता है अटैक य इसने बता रखा है
तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं हमारे पास
इंफॉर्मेशन है गेस्ट मोड में है इसका
काउंट यूज ऑथेंटिकेशन लेवल यूजर्स है तो
अभी हम क्या करते हैं तो अभी हमारे पास ये
इंफॉर्मेशन आ गई अभी हम सेशंस फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करते हैं कि कौन-कौन से
सेशन है इसके ऊपर अभी अभी चेक करते उसके
लिए होता है ए मैप हा
देखो व्ट टाइप ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन देखो एमरे
देखा रेशन में कितनी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं एक हान हान
स्क्रिप्ट हाइन हान स्क्रिप्ट देन
स्क्रिप्ट का नाम है एसएमबी हाइन एनम हाइन
सेशन अब सेशन की इंफॉर्मेशन
हाइन सेशन उसके बाद
192.168 222 ओके सो एसएमबी न्यूमरेशन य है
एसम बी
एनम सेशन हिट एटर
यह देखिए अ यह क्या बता रहा आपको कि
रिपोर्टेड होस्ट जज अप अ य इस कोई भी सेशन
मेंटेन नहीं किया गया किसके साथ एसएमबी के
साथ अगर कोई भी सेशन मेंटेन होता तो य
आपको बता
देता तो अभी य इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट की
नेक्स्ट एक स्क्रिप्ट होती है प्रोटोकॉल्स
वाली एन मैप हाइ फन प पप फ उसके बाद हाइन
हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट सबको दिखाई दे रहा होगा उसके
बाद एसएमबी हाइ फन प्रोटोकॉल प्रोटोकॉल्स
उसके बाद ये रहा हिट एंटर ये सेम चीज आपको
बता रहा है एसएमबी वर्जन डेंजरस बट जो
इसने आपको बताया सेम जो हमने किससे पता
किया था एसएमबी प्रोटो ओके ऑलरेडी सेम ही
है तो नाउ अभी हमारे पास ये सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन
है यहां तक सबको समझ में आया कि एन मैप के
थ्रू हमें एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल जो एनएससी
स्क्रिप्ट है या एसएमबी एनम के थ्रू कैसे
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं व्ट
टाइप ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन एसएमबी सिक्योरिटी मोड
सबको क्लियर है यहां
तक अभी जैसे शेयर की इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करता हूं इसके ऊपर व बाद
में करूंगा मैं आपको शेयर की इंफॉर्मेशन
तो व कैसे फाइंड आउट करेंगे हम देखते
हैं अभी मैं आपको किसके थ्रू दिखाता हूं
एक
बार एमएसएफ कंसोल के थ्रू इंफॉर्मेशन
दिखाता हूं
ओके या रिप्लाई तो
करो तो सबसे पहले आपको क्या करना
है सर्विस
स्टार्ट कौन सी
पोस्ट ग्री
एसक्यूएल सिस्टम सीटीएल कर दो अगर सिस्टम
सीटीएल स्टार्ट पोस्ट एएल ऐसे करोगे तो
आपकी सर्विस स्टार्ट हो जाएगी अगर फिर भी
किसी को लगता है आपकी सर्विस स्टार्ट नहीं
हो रही तो आप एक काम करो एटी इंस्टॉल
पोस्ट ग्रीस एसक्यूएल को इंस्टॉल कर लो हो
सकता है आपके पास पुराना वर्जन हो रहा
होगा ये सिंक्रोनाइज नहीं कर रहे होंगे तो
मेरे साथ भी हुआ था जब मैंने काफी टाइम
बाद अभी क्लास से पहले यूज किया था तो सेम
इशू हुआ था ये स्टार्ट नहीं हो रहा था तो
उसके बाद आप जैसे करोगे सिस्टम सीटीएल
स्टार्ट पोस्ट ग्री एसक्यूएल तो ये
स्टार्ट हो जाएगी अब इसका स्टेटस देखने के
लिए सिस्टम सीटीएल स्टेटस
स्टेटस
पोस्ट पोस्ट एसकल य रहा एक्टिव है सर्विस
हमारी अभी हम क्या करेंगे एमएसएफ कंसोल को
ऑन करते हैं हमारे मेटा स्लेट फ्रेमवर्क
को अभी हम क्या करते मेटा फम को ऑन करते
हैं उसके बाद कंटिन्यू करेंगे
कोई नहीं हुसैन कोई नहीं कोई नहीं
विल टेक टाइम अभी मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा कि
अभी एक छोटा सा ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक करके कि
अगर हम बाय डिफॉल्ट जो कॉमन वर्ड लिस्ट के
थ्रू हम क्या करेंगे एक छोटा सा ब्रूट
फोर्स अटैक भी ट्राई करेंगे यह फाइंड आउट
करने के लिए कि जो कॉमन क्योंकि बाय
डिफॉल्ट कॉन्फिन इसका मतलब कॉमन पासवर्ड
भी हो सकते हैं यूजर्स ने अगर स्ट्रांग
पासवर्ड नहीं रखा होगा तो हम क्या कर
ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक करेंगे अगर हमें
क्रैडेंशियल्स मिलते हैं तो हम फिर
क्रेडेंशियल से भी क्या करेंगे और भी
ज्यादा इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश करेंगे तो अभी मैं एक टेक्निक
दिखाऊंगा किसके थ्रू एमएसएफ कंसोल के थ्रू
कैसे हम ब्रूट फोर्स करेंगे एसएमबी के ऊपर
लेकिन जब हमारे सेशंस आएंगे जब हम एसएमबी
के थ्रू क्या करेंगे सेल गेट इन करेंगे
एसएमबी के थ्रू सिस्टम को हैक करेंगे उस
केस में मैं दूसरे से ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक
दिखाऊंगा और हाइड्रा जैसे टूल का यूज करके
उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे फिर फर्द एक्सेस
गेन करेंगे और उसके बाद उसके अंदर हम
फ्लैग फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करेंगे या
फर्द हम सेशन को मेंटेन करने की कोशिश
करेंगे सारी टेक्निक हम सीखने वाले हैं
अपकमिंग क्लासेस में
ओके मेटा स्लेट अभी स्टार्ट हो रहा
है अभी हम फिर से क क्रॉस चेक कर लेते हैं
क्या मैं डेटाबेस कनेक्ट हुआ या नहीं हुआ
कई बार हम डायरेक्टली रन कर लेते हैं एसएफ
कंसोल को तो ऐसे भी चेक कर सकते हैं कि
मेरा जो जो डेटाबेस एमएसडीबी वाली जो
सर्विस स्टार्ट हुई या नहीं जो पोस्ट ग्रस
एसक्यूएल जो सर्वर है वो स्टार्ट होना
चाहिए तो डीबी स्टेटस एसटी एटी यू एस
स्टेटस हिट एंटर तोय आपको बता रहा है ओके
सेलेक्ट सिलेक्टेड नो कनेक्शन
ओके एक्टिव होगा ओके हां यही आएगा उसके
बाद अभी मैं क्या करता हूं अभी मेरे पास
कुछ एसएमबी से रिलेटेड भी हम यूज करते हैं
अभी मैं सबसे पहले एक वर्कस्पेस क्रिएट
करता हूं एसएमबी से रिलेटेड वर्कस्पेस
हाइन ए आप सबको पता है वर्क स्पेस कैसे हम
यूज करते हैं सबको पता
है मैंने आपको सिखाया सबको आता
है
एसएमबी डाटा बेस नॉट कनेक्टेड
ओके एक बार मैं क्या करता
हूं स्टेटस
सेम एरर थी क्या
आपकी
चलो एम
एसडीबी ट एंटर करते हैं एमएसडीबी हाइन
एच ओके एम एस एफडीबी
यह रहा अभी मैं एक बार क्या इलाज कर देता
हूं ए डीवी इनिला इज आई एन आई टी इनिला
फर्स्ट टाइम यूज कर तो आपको इलाज करना
होगा फर्स्ट टाइम आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
इलाज करना
होगा तो चंदन देख लिया अगर फर्स्ट टाइम कर
रहे होगे तो आपको क्या करना है पोस्ट गल
सर्विस को स्टार्ट करना है देन उसके बाद
इट करना इलाज करना आपको डेटाबेस को देन
ओनली आप यूज कर पाओगे देखो अभी डेटाबेस
इलाज हो रहा
आपका आज अच्छा लगा कि आज 48 स्टूडेंट है
थोड़ा सा अच्छा लग रहा है बट अगर 100 या
60 70 चलते हैं तो और भी इंटरेस्टिंग रहता
है नो ू अभी हम एक काम करते हैं अभी दूसरी
स्क्रीन पर सेट चलते य रहा अभी फिर से चेक
करते हैं यह रहा डीवी स्टेटस सिलेक्टेड एक
मिनट डेटाबेस नॉट कनेक्टेड व्हाट इज द इशू
विथ ट हम इसको एक बार एग्जिट करते हैं
इट विल टेक टाइम अदर वाइज हम क्या करेंगे
दूसरी मशीन को स्टार्ट अप रख रखते हैं
करते हैं फिर तो हमारे पास दूसरी मशीन भी
है ना
यह रही पैरेट वस को स्टार्ट कर देंगे
हमारे पास क्या है कोई नहीं पैरेट वस न हो
जाएगा तब
तक मेरे पास रिसोर्सेस की कमी है
नहीं ये आपको पता ही है
मैं कितनी भी मशीने ऑन कर सकता
हूं ओके तब तक इसको देखते हैं अभी
हां दोनों अलग है
यार देखो मेटा स् पलट क्या है आपका
एक फ्रेमवर्क मतलब एक डेटाबेस है जहां पर
बहुत सारे एक्सप्लो आपके लिए क्या किया
गया है एक ऑटोमेशन आपकी जो पेनिट्रेशन
लाइफ साइकिल को ऑटोमेट करने के लिए बनाया
गया है मेटा स्पले टेबल क्या है बनाया
रैपिड से नहीं है लेकिन वो वल्नरेबल मशीन
है उनके ऊपर प्रैक्टिस करने के लिए जब
बिगनर लेवल पर आप बहुत सारी जैसे कि थन
ब्लू है या बहुत सारी जो वनटी है उनकी
प्रैक्टिस के लिए
वह इंटेंशनली बनाई गई वल्नरेबल मशीनस
है डीपी
स्टेटस ओके अभी देखो वर्किंग कंडीशन है
अभी वर्क स्पेस
वर्कस्पेस हाइन ए उसके बाद
एसएमबी क्रिएट करते हैं हिट
एंटर वर्क स्पेस क्रिएट होगी अभी मैं
क्रॉस चेक कर लेता हूं क्या कौन सी वर्क
स्पेस के अंदर
हूं ओके वेट वेट वेट
ओके हम एसएमबी वर्क स्पेस के अंदर है अभी
हमारे पास क्या है हमें सर्च करना है
एसएमबी की कौन सी फाइल ऑक्सल हम कौन सा
मॉड्यूल यूज करेंगे न्यूमरेशन में लरी
मॉड्यूल तो हम क्या करेंगे
सर्च सर्च टाइप कौन सा मेरा लरी मॉड्यूल
ऑरी मॉड्यूल आपको पता है
लरी उसके बाद नेम क्या है एसएमबी नेम कौन
सा मेरा ओके ओके ओके भैया क्या हो
गया एसएमबी
बहुत टाइम ले रहा है अब इसमें मेटा
एक्सप्लोइट मेरा
सीपीय यूसेज कुछ नहीं है और पता
नहीं गाइस न इसको एक बार रि स्टार्ट कर
देते हैं हम
पूरी मशीन स्मूथली चल रही है बस काली नेस
के साथ प्रॉब्लम हो रहा
है इतना तो पैरेट भी नहीं करता मेरा
मैंने भी लेटेस्ट वर्जन डाउनलोड किया है
ना तो इंस्टॉल किया है तो ये लेटेस्ट
वर्जन पता नहीं क्या ग्लिच है इसमें क्या
इशू है कितने भी रिसोर्सेस दे दो इसको
प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट करता है
ये आप सभी का भी प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट करता है
क्या
मैंने इसको 8gb रम दिया फिर भी प्रॉब्लम
क्रिएट कर रहा
है अदर वाइज क्या करेंगे प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट
कर रहा तो हम फिर पैरेट ऐसे ही करते हैं
इसको हम क्लोज कर देते हैं
पैरेट
मैंने फालतू बंद कर दिया पैरेट जो पहले
स्टार्ट हो जा उसे करते हैं अगर होगा तो
ठीक है नहीं तो
फिर क्लास को नेक्स्ट क्लास में पढ़ाना
होगा क्योंकि अभी मैं एमबी न्यूमरेशन को
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेट करवाना चाह रहा
हूं आप लोगों को दिखाना चाह रहा हूं एन
मैप के थ्रू ही दिखा पाया हूं अभी ऑटोमेशन
वे दिखा ही नहीं पाया तो फिर फायदा नहीं
होगा प्रैक्टिकल तो आपका दिखाना बहुत
ज्यादा जरूरी है दोनों सांबा पे भी और
आपका एसएमबी के ऊपर भी तो इसलिए प्रॉब्लम
है मैं सोच रहा आज की क्लास में कंप्लीट
हो जाए
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक आपको सीखना है तो आप एक
काम कीजिए आपको मिल जाएगा कोर्स जल्दी यह
डेनिक्स प भी अवेलेबल है डेफ भी डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक के कोर्स करवाता है साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन के भी करवाता है तो डेफ
उसके पास सारे कोर्सेस है और अपकमिंग टाइम
में शॉक के भी शक एनालिस्ट के कोर्सेस भी
अवेलेबल होंगे
आर्मी टेक था एक मैं आपको बताया था वो भी
इसका अल्टरनेटिव है वह भी यूज कर सकते
हो क्योंकि व भी मेटा स्प्ड फ्रेमवर्क का
यूज करता है
इतना टाइम मिलता ही नहीं है सीटीएफ खेलने
का बट आप लोगों के क्लासेस में सीटीएफ प
करवाऊंगी
ट्रिक्स टेक्निक आपको बता दूंगा इतना टाइम
नहीं मिलता या मेरे को कि आप लोग की क्लास
भी रेडी करो मैं सीटी भी खेलू इतना टाइम
मुझे नहीं मिलता ओके तो अब फिर से हम
ट्राई करते हैं इसी चीज को एमएसएफ कंसोल
को सबको फंट का साइज सही है क्लियर है
नहीं यार पूरी इंडस्ट्री तो एन मैप को यूज
करती है और आप बोल रहे हो कि अलाव नहीं
करती कंपनियां मेरे को तो कभी किसी ने
नहीं मना किया
ओके इसको हम स्टार्ट कर देते
हैं नाउ रनिंग अभी एक काम करते हैं एमएसएफ
डीबी
हा एमएसएफ
कंसोल फिर से ट्राई करते
हैं हां दोनों अलग-अलग है लेकिन थोड़ा
बहुत फॉरेंसिक व यूज करते हैं मतलब दोनों
अलग अलग कोर्सेस
है फॉरेंसिक व भी यूज करते
हैं साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन तो सारा
ही फॉरेंसिक यूज होता है बेसिकली
आई हैव कवर द ओल्ड
क्लासेस फर्स्ट एमएसएफ अभी भी पूरा
नहीं कर पाए आई डोंट नो कि आप क्या कहना
चाह रहे
हो तो कार्बन आपका ओरिजिनल नाम मुझे नहीं
पता इस चीज की गारंटी है कि आप जब यह मेरा
कोर्स कंप्लीट कर लोगे यह जो अभी कोर्स
में आपको पढ़ा रहा हूं ईजी पीटी का आप
एग्जाम दे सकते हो टोटल 35 क्वेश्चन आते
हैं उसका आप एग्जाम दे सकते
हो उसके लिए आपको कोई भी अलग से कोर्स
पढ़ने की जरूरत नहीं है
आपको कुछ भी अलग से कहीं पर भी कहीं भी
जाने की जरूरत नहीं है आप सिंपली क्या कर
सकते हो यहीं से सीख सकते
हो
ओके ना एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं हम डीबी
स्टेटस आपको वही बता रहा हूं आप जो सीच
बोलते हो ईजी पीएटी बोलते हो या बेसिक लेव
जो सर्टिफिकेशन है आपको कहीं पर भी जाने
की जरूरत नहीं है आप यहां से सीख सकते हो
क्योंकि यह कोर्स वही लेवल का है उसके बाद
आप एडवांस प शिफ्ट कर सकते हो चाहो तो
लेकिन उसका एडवांस वर्जन भी हमारे पास
अवेलेबल है जो ऑलरेडी ऑन गोइंग कोर्स चल
रहा है और जो नेक्स्ट बैच भी आएगा जिसको
हम डीसीएसपी बोलते हैं उसमें वो सारा
एडवांस वर्जन है आप चाहो तो जिनकी बात कर
रहे हो पीएन पीटी या व्हाट एवर जो भी
एक्स्ट्रा जो रेड टीमिंग सर्टिफिकेशन होते
हैं आप अगर उनको करना चाहो तो आपके पास
अगर ज्यादा पैसे पे है तो आप दे सकते हो
कक हम भी एक अपना सर्टिफिकेशन लेकर आने
वाले हैं कि जिसका कॉमिनेशन रहेगा यह जो
कोर्स मैं पढ़ा रहा हूं जो फ्री वाला प्लस
में डीसीएसपी सिक्स मंथ डिप्लोमा कोर्स है
उसका दोनों का कॉमिनेशन मिलाकर हम एक एक
मास्टर एग्जाम लेंगे जो टोटली आपका क्या
क्या रहेगा रेड टीमिंग सर्टिफिकेट रहेगा
रेड टीमिंग कोर्स चलो कोर्स प फोकस करते
हैं अभी
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं सर्च करता
हूं सर्च टाइप
लरी ए
यू टाइप लरी और नेम कौन सी सर्विस मैं
एसएमबी के लिए फाइंड आउट कर रहा हूं एस
एमबी हिट
एंटर विदाउट कॉलेज डिग्री के प्रॉब्लम
क्या आपकी सीवी पर इफेक्ट पड़ता है आपके
पास एटलीस्ट मिनिमम लेवल बीसीए होनी चाहिए
बीसीए तो होना ही
चाहिए विदाउट डिग्री आपको डेफिनेटली
प्रॉब्लम होगी आपको कंपनी आसपास भी नहीं
आने देगी
बिल्कुल अखिलेश क्योंकि मैडस प्लट एंड मैप
आपका टाइम सेविंग के लिए सबसे पहले फास्ट
आप इन्हीं को यूज करते हो उसके बाद आपको
लगता है कि इनसे कुछ नहीं मिल रहा तब आप
मैनुअल जाते हो एक बार आप टाइम सेविंग के
लिए क्योंकि जो बाय डिफॉल्ट डेटाबेस
अवेलेबल होता है बाय डिफॉल्ट जो वल्नरेबल
है वर्जन स्पेसिफिक जो अभी तक रिलीज हुई
है तो वो आप ऑटोमेटिक ट्राई कर लेते हो
क्योंकि कंपनिया तो प्रोफेशनल वर्जन यूज
करती कमर्शियल यूज करती है इफ अगर आई एम
राइट बिल्कुल सॉल्व करना पड़ता
है बहुत टाइम ले रहा है यार बहुत टाइम
इतना टाइम मेरे इसमें मेटा स्ट तो बहुत
प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट कर रहा है
पिसने का इलीगल है
एक काम करते हैं अभी इसको
[संगीत]
हम पैरेट पर लेकर चलते हैं यार बहुत हो
गया अभी मैं पैरेट इस को यूज करने वाला
हूं शट डाउन द मशीन नथिंग शट
डाउन शट
डाउन यह माय पैरेट वास
ओके बहुत टाइम वेस्ट करवा दिया
हमारा मशीन
ने दद ये ना करवाए
वाओ
यार सबको दिखाई दे रहा है अभी क्लियर
ना अभी हम क्या करते हैं बस
अभी मैं वर्क स्पेस यूज नहीं करूंगा मैं
डायरेक्टली बाय डिफॉल्ट वर्क स्पेस में
काम करूंगा क्योंकि मुझे ये रिपोर्ट किसी
को रिप्रेजेंट नहीं करनी है अभी के
लिए ओके फट साइज और बड़ा करना है ओके ओके
मैं करता हूं इसको फुल कर देता हूं यह रहा
यस चलेगा
अभी एंड आई एम सॉरी गाइस क्योंकि ना तो
आपके हाथ में यह चीजें ना ही मेरे हाथ में
है क्योंकि यह प्रॉब्लम किसकी है मशीन की
अगली बार से हम पैरेट व प्रेफर प्रेफरेंस
देंगे ओके अभी हम क्या करते
हैं
सर्च
टाइप कोई स्पेलिंग एरर तो प्लीज मुझे इंफो
कर
देना ओके देखिए यहां से रिजल्ट मिल गया
अभी इसमें क्या है दे लॉट ऑफ अभी थोड़ा सा
जूम आउट कर लेता हूं ताकि आपको क्लियर
दिखे
यह रहा अभी इसमें बहुत सारी ऑक्ल
स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल
है ये ऑरी मॉड्यूल अवेलेबल है जो आप यूज
कर सकते हो किसके लिए एसएमबी न्यूमरेशन के
लिए अ जैसे एसएमबी वर्जन एसएमबी एनम यूजर
एसबी ट्री कनेक्ट व्ट एवर अभी हम सबसे
पहले क्या कौन सी यूज करने वाले हैं
एसएमबी एसएमबी वर्जन यह वाली
एसएमबी कहां गया वर्जन यह वाली 39 वाली हम
सिंपली क्या करेंगे प एंड इसको हम क्या
करें यूज यूज और कंट्रोल शिफ्ट v और शिट
एंटर कर दिया अभी यूज किया अभी हम चेक
करते हैं इसके लिए हमें कौन-कौन से ऑप्शन
सेट करने पड़े
सो ऑप्शंस ये देखिए अभी मुझे यहां पर आर
होस्ट टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस सेट करना होगा
आर पोर्ट नो टारगेट पोर्ट आईपी वैसे आपको
सेट करने की जरूरत नहीं है थ्रेड चलने
देंगे अभी मैं चेक कर लेता हूं मेरा
टारगेट अभी ऑन भी है या नहीं है पिंग
192.168
ड
222 ट एंटर ओके वर्किंग कंडीशन में नो इशू
अभी मैं क्या करता हूं सेट आर
होस्ट आर होस्ट देन उसके बाद
192.168
डॉट 2 अभी हम विंडो पर कर रहे हैं हिट
एंटर यह देखिए सेट कर दिया अभी स
ऑप्शन सेट हो गया अभी सीधी मैं कर देता
हूं रन कर देता हूं हिट
एंटर डायरेक्टली मैंने इस पर रन कर दिया
अब यह क्या बता रहा है 445 एसएमबी
डिटेक्टेड वर्जन वन कमा टू प्रेफर्ड
डायलेक्स बता रहा है 2.1 आपको बता रहा है
ऑप्शनल अप टाइम व्ट एवर ये जीयू आईडी बता
रहा है उसकी ऑथेंटिकेशन डोमेन अभी इसने
डोमेन नेम बता दिया यहां पर आपको डोमेन
नेम भी पता चल गया उसके बास होस्ट की
इंफॉर्मेशन विज स 2008 r2 स्टैंडर्ड ए1
अभी कई बार हो सकता है कि यहां पर आपको जो
ये विंडोज कई बार होस्ट की इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको गलत भी मिल सकती है कई बार नेगेटिव
भी मिल सकती है मतलब हो सकता है और कुछ
वर्जन चल रहा है या और कुछ रनिंग हो लेकिन
आपको यह इंफॉर्मेशन गलत भी दे सकता है तो
यह आपको क्रॉस वेरीफाई करनी होगी और अदर
टूल के साथ या आप
इस वनटी को फाइंड आउट करके इसके अगेंस्ट
वनटी को फाइंड आउट करके तो एक तो मैंने
आपको बताया एमबी वर्जन दूसरा मैंने आपको
और भी बताई थी जैसे कि अभी हम क्या करते
हैं फिर से बैक करते
हैं अ टर्मिनल को क्लियर कर लेता हूं देन
उसके बाद फिर से यह रही और भी स्क्रिप्ट
और भी स्क्रिप्ट रन से पहले दिस वन दिस वन
दिस वन नो
नो यह रहा
ओके हिट एंटर
अरे
[संगीत]
यार इतनी देर में तुम
सर्च टाइप लरी हर बार मुझे टाइप ही करना
पड़ेगा एसम बी यह रहा अभी मैं यूज करने
वाला हूं ऑरी स्कैनर एसएमबी एनम यूजर्स
एनम यूज में फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश कर
रहा हूं
देखिए कॉपी किया और सिंपली यूज आप चाहो तो
नंबर के साथ उसके अगेंस्ट आईडी दी हुई है
ना व भी कर सकते हो आप यह रहा ट
एंटर अभी हम क्या कर दिस मॉडल कैन टारगेट
ए सेशन और एन आर होस्ट ओके एसम बी अभी हम
क्या करते
इधर अभी हम चेक करते हैं ब ऑप्शन स
ऑप्शंस
य पोर्ट इसमें डिफाइंड है एसएमबी डोमेन नो
एसएमबी पासवर्ड यूजर नेम हमारे पास है
नहीं अभी सिंपली हम क्या कर सकते हैं सेट
कर देते हैं आर
होस्ट ट एंटर
अभी हम क्या करते हैं
रन कंप्लीट एरर नो मैच एरर अनडिफाइंड मेथड
डोमेन हैंडल फॉर नल ओके स्कैन अभी यहां पर
कुछ भी आउटपुट आपको देखने को नहीं मिला
आपके यूजर नेम से रिलेटेड ओके आपको कुछ भी
नहीं मिला अभी मैं क्या करता हूं शेयर से
रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करता हूं शर
से रिलेटेड इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने के
लिए मेरे पास मॉड्यूल का नाम पता है
मॉड्यूल है मेरा
लरी य आप सर्च कर सकते हो एक मॉड्यूल होता
है ऑक्ल उसके बाद
स्कैनर उसके बाद आपका
एसएमबी एसएमबी उसके बाद क्या है एसएमबी
अंडर स्कोर एनम शेयर एनम
शेयर अभी उसके बाद यह रहा यूज करेंगे हम
उसके बाद श ऑप्शन
यहां पर देखिए ऑटोमेशन तरीका है यहां पर
देखो अभी यह क्या है आर होस्ट और यहां पर
हम चेक करते हैं यह रहा इस इंफॉर्मेशन है
अभी हम क्या हम आर सेट करना पड़ेगा
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड हमारे पास नहीं है तो
सेट 19
2.1.0 हिट एंटर अभी हम क्या करते हैं अभी
रन कर देते हैं
डायरेक्टली यह ब है स्टेटस एक्सेस डिनाइड
नॉट ए वैलिड एसएमबी
पैकेट हमारी मशीन तो ऑन है बट व्हाट इज द
इशू विद दैट इसको शो करना चाहिए बट यह कुछ
भी शो नहीं कर रहा इधर
ओके ओके ओके ओके एक ऑप्शन सेट करना था
हमें यहां पर आई
मिस्टेक ऑप्शंस यह रहा हमें यह तो सेट कर
लिया एमबी यूजर नेम पासवर्ड हमारे पास
नहीं है आर होस्ट हमने सेट कर लिया डोमेन
डॉट रहेगा हमारा ऊपर यह ही श फाइल था यह
आपको श डिटेल्स इंफॉर्मेशन न स्पाइडरिंग
यह आपको क्या करना था ट्रू करना था यह
ऑप्शन आपको क्या करना था ट्रू करना था ओके
नाउ सेट
ट्रू नाउ अभी करना हमें
एक्सप्लोइट अभी भी कुछ नहीं दिखा रहा है
यह कुछ भी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको शो नहीं कर रहा
यह क्या नॉट एडी एसएमबी पैकेट व्ट इ सम
एरर्स विथ प्रॉब्लम ट
चलो अभी हम क्या कर रहे हैं अभी यहां पर
कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन हमें देखने को नहीं मिल
रही कोई इशू नहीं है तो अभी हम क्या करते
हैं अभी इसको बैक कर देते
हैं अभी इसके अंदर एक मॉड्यूल होता है
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए एसएमबी लॉगइन
मॉड्यूल एसएमबी लॉगिन मॉड्यूल तो देखो अभी
हम मैं आपको ब्रूट फोर्स परफॉर्म करके
दिखाता हूं और इसके अगेंस्ट यूजर नेम एंड
पासवर्ड फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं
कैसे अभी हम चेक करते हैं कि सर्च
टाइप
ऑक्सल
टाइप तो यह रहा
हमारा अभी हम देखते हैं इसके अंदर
एसएमबी अभी हमने कुछ और गलत सेट किया
क्या ओके नेम एसम बी चाहिए था
हमें तो पता नहीं इस केस में भी कीबोर्ड
क्या प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट कर रहा
है य रहा एसएमबी तो ये होता आपका एक है
इसमें स्क्रिप्ट एसएमबी लॉग इन करके होगी
र ब लॉगइन यूज 25 करते हैं हम
यूज
25 हमने किया तो न्यू इन 6.4 द क्रिएट
सेशन ऑप्शन विद इन दिस मड कैन ओपन एन
इंटरेक्ट सेशन इट्स ओके अभी हम क्या करते
हैं इंफो देखिए अग इसके अंदर ये क्या
करेगा यह रहा ये इसकी डिटेल प्रोवाइड कर
दे आपको दिस मॉडल विल टेस्ट ए एसएमबी
लॉगिन ऑन ए रेंज ऑफ मशीनस एंड रिपोर्ट
सक्सेसफुल लॉगिन इफ यू हैव लोडेड ए
डेटाबेस प्लगइन एंड कनेक्टेड टू डेटाबेस
दिस मड विल रिकॉर्ड सक्सेसफुली लॉगिन एंड
होस्ट यू कैन ट्रैक योर एक्सेस ओके तो अभी
हम क्या करते हैं इसको क्लियर कर देते हैं
और ऑप्शंस चेक करते
हैं सो ऑप्शंस
यह रहा अभी दे आ लॉट ऑफ ऑप्शंस यहां पर
देखो यस फॉल्स है ये देख एनोनिमस लॉगिन हम
ट्राई नहीं करने वाले ब्लैंक पासवर्ड नो
ब्रूट फोर्स स्पीड बाय डिफॉल्ट रहनी देते
हैं हम उसके बाद डीबी ये सारी चीजें बाय
डिफॉल्ट रहनी देते हैं और हम हम यहां रखते
हैं प्रॉक्सीस हमें नहीं यूज करना वाला
देखो आर होस्ट हम सेट
करेंगे उसके बाद हम आर पोर्ट हमारा सेट है
एसएमबी डोमेन द विंडोज डोमेन टू यूज फॉर
ऑथेंटिकेशन ओके एसएमबी पासवर्ड द पासवर्ड
फॉर द स्पेसिफाइड यूजर नेम एसएमबी यूजर्स
नो हमारे पास नहीं है तो अब हम क्या
करेंगे स्टॉप ऑन सक्सेस यस स्टॉप गेसिंग
व्हेन ए क्रेडेंशियल वर्क फॉर ए होस्ट या
थ्रेड्स वन यूजर पासवर्ड फाइल हम यहां
क्या करेंगे यूज यूजर पास फाइल द फाइल
कंटेनिंग यूजर एंड पासवर्ड सेपरेटेड बाय
स्पेस वन पेयर पर लाइन ये नहीं यूज करने
वाले हम यूज करें देखो यूजर्स एज पास
फाल्स ट्राई द यूजर नेम एज द पासवर्ड फॉर
ऑल द यूजर्स एंड यूजर फाइल फाइल कंटेनिंग
यूजर नेम वन लाइन पर यूजर नेम एक यूजर
फाइल ब्रूट फोर्सिंग के लिए हम इसको यूज
करने वाले हैं ओके तो कैसे करेंगे हम सेट
कर देते हैं इसको ओके तो इसको हम क्या कर
देते हैं अभी सेट कर देते हैं तो हम अभी
एक बाय डिफॉल्ट वर्ड लिस्ट होती है किसके
अंदर मेटा स्प्ड के अंदर तो उस वर्ड लिस्ट
हम यूज करने वाले हैं और व लिस्ट उसके बेस
में फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करते कि
सक्सेसफुल कोई लॉगिन मिलता है या नहीं
मिलता तो हम क्या करते हैं
अभी यूजर फाइल और एक पास फाइल होगी इसके
अंदर यह रही तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं सेट
सबसे पहले आर
होस्ट 192.168
सबको समझ में आ रहा एवरीवन
बताइए बताइए बता बताइए क्या चल रहा है या
बोर हो रहे हो बता देना मेरे को अभी हम
क्या करते हैं सेट अभी यूजर फाइल हम य
वर्ड लिस्ट मेंशन करेंगे इसके अंदर
कॉपी पेस्ट यूजर फाइल और यहां पर मेंशन
करेंगे कौन सी वर्ड लिस्ट अभी वर्ड लिस्ट
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए एक काम कर देता हूं
मैं हमारी
एप्लीकेशंस ना नो नो
नो ये रहा हम फाइल सिस्टम के अंदर चलते
हैं नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं हम
ओके वाह वा बैक बैक थोड़ सा जूम कर दूं
आपके लिए हम वर्डलिस्ट देखेंगे
अभी यूजर यूजर के अंदर हम क्या करेंगे
शेयर के अंदर जाएंगे यूजर शेयर अभी शेयर
यहां जूम कर देता हूं मैं शेयर को शेयर के
अंदर हम जाएंगे मेटा स्लोट फ्रेमवर्क मेटा
स्लोट फ्रेमवर्क
मल्टी गो मेटा स्ड वि मेटा फेम
वर्क ये रहा डबल क्लिक ऑन द मेटा स्प
मेड पट के अंदर एक डाटा होगा डाटा डाटा के
अंदर हम क्या करेंगे अभी आपको जूम कर देता
हूं ये रहा मम डाटा के अंदर होती है वर्ड
लिस्ट डाटा के अंदर आपकी क्या है वर्ड
लिस्ट अब ये सारी वर्ड लिस्ट अवेलेबल आपकी
बाय डिफॉल्ट जब भी मेटा पट इंस्टॉल करते
है अ कौन सी वर्ड लिस्ट यूज करने वाले
होंगे हम यूज करेंगे कॉमन इसके अंदर हम
देखते
[संगीत]
हैं
यूनिक्स यूनिक्स या ओके हम यूनिक्स वाली
यूज करके देखते हैं एक बार कोई अवेलेबल है
कॉमन देखते हैं कहां ग
इसमें यूनिस यूनिक्स यूनिक्स य यूनिक्स
पासवर्ड यूनिक्स यूजर्स यूजर एक्सटी हम
करके देखेंगे अगर इसको आपको डबल क्लिक
करके देखना तो व भी देख सकते हो
आप य फुल वर्ड लिस्ट आपके सामने देखो इस
तरीके से है
ओके तो अभी हम क्या करते इसको क्लोज करते
हैं और इस वर्ड लिस्ट को मैं उसके अंदर
मेंशन करूंगा हमारे टर्मिनल के अंदर ओके
यार यह रहा तो सेट हम य करेंगे फ
यूजर शेयर के अंदर मेटा स्प
फ्रेमवर्क हाई फन
फ्रेमवर्क फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर डाटा डाटा के
वर्ड लिस्ट वर्ड लिस्ट के अंदर हमारा क्या
है
यूनिक्स उसके बाद यूजर यूनिक्स
यूजर डटी एक्सटी ओके यह सेट कर देता हूं
हिट एंटर हमने सेट कर दिया ऐसे हम क्या
करेंगे सेट पास फाइल सेट करेंगे यह यहां
वाली कॉपी
यूनिक्स
अंडरस्कोर पास व डटी एक्सटी सेट दो वर्ड
लिस्ट मैंने मेंशन कर दिए इसके अंदर अभी
मैं श ऑप्शन चेक कर लेता
हूं अभी हम कोई भी एरर नहीं करना चाहेंगे
अभी यह वर्ड लिस्ट सेट है यहां पर भी वर्ड
लिस्ट सेट है टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस सेट है
पोट 445 है और सिंपली हम क्या करते हैं
एक्सप्लो को रन करते
हैं आप कोई भी वर्ड लिस्ट यूज कर सकते हो
अभी हम इसको यूज करते हैं रन कर देता ह
सिंपली हिट एंटर यह
देखिए जहां पर आपको सक्सेस मिलेगी वहां पर
आपको यहां पर देखो रेड की ग्रीन टिक मिल
जाएगा
यहां पर हमारा चल रहा है ब्रूट फोर्स
अटैक अभी ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक आपका डिपेंड
करता है आपकी वर्ड लिस्ट के ऊपर कोई भी
ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक तभी सक्सेस होता है अगर
आपके पास एक सक्सेसफुल वर्ड लिस्ट हो आपके
पास उसका जो यूजर्स नेम क्या के लिए जो
यूजर है उसके लिए आपका जो अजमन है वो आप
वो वर्ड्स का कॉमिनेशन आपकी वर्ड लिस्ट के
अंदर होना चाहिए और जो पासवर्ड का जो अजमन
है जो आपने अजूम किया है इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग के थ्रू या जो भी आपने वर्ड लिस्ट
क्रिएट की है वो उसका अजमन आपकी वर्ड
लिस्ट के अंदर होना चाहिए तभी आपका ब्रूट
फोर्स अटैक सक्सेस होता है अदर
वाइज आप सक्सेस नहीं हो पाओगे
लो यार टर्मिनल को और बड़ा कर
देंगे इट विल टेक टाइम
अे वर्डलिस्ट वैसे तो देखिए कि जो कॉमन व
वर्डलिस्ट है आपकी गिट हप पर अवेलेबल है
लेकिन
अगर आपके पास यह इंफॉर्मेशन है कि जो
पासवर्ड पॉलिसी किस टाइप की है आपके सामने
मशीन की जो कंपनी है किस टाइप की पासवर्ड
पॉलिसीज को यूज कर रही है किस टाइप के
उसमें यूजर नेम्स हो सकते हैं इस टाइप की
आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन है तो आपको खुद की
वर्डलिस्ट क्रिएट करनी होगी और आपको
डिफाइन करना होगा क्योंकि हर एक पासवर्ड
की एक लेंथ होगी डिपेंड करता भी यूजर्स ने
उस लेंथ को कितना है कि एग्जैक्ट उसी लेंथ
को सेट किया या उसे आगे पीछे कर दिया होगा
तो यह क्या है घंटों नी दिनों की मेहनत है
यह आपके पास एक अच्छी वर्ड लिस्ट या तो आप
खुद को क्रिएट करनी पड़ेगी या एक बार आप
फर्स्ट अटेंप्ट में क्या कर सकते हो ब्रूट
फोर्स कॉमन वर्डली से ट्राई कर सकते हो कि
अगर डिफॉल्ट कॉन्फ़िगरेशन होगी मशीन की या
कॉमन पासवर्ड रहा होगा तो प्र क्या होगा
कॉमन पासवर्ड से आपके चांसेस आपको मिलने
के अभी मुझे नहीं पता यहां पर कितना
सक्सेस रेट है और कितना फेलियर रेट
है लेकिन आपको इतना बता देता हूं कि इसके
अंदर वह पासवर्ड्स हैं यूजर नेम और
पासवर्ड है
वह भी कर सकते हैं उसका तरीका अलग है वह
डायरेक्टली आप आपको ज्यादातर कौन से केस
में देखा आपने अगर देखोगे ना कि आप वाईफाई
हैकिंग करते हो ना उसमें आपको कभी जो रन
करते हो ब्रूट फोर्सिंग को ट्राई करते हो
पासवर्ड के ऊपर डब्ल्यू पीए टू के ऊपर या
डब्ल्यूपी हैंड शेक के ऊपर वहां देखना आप
वन वन वर्ड शिप करके आप चेक करते रहते हो
पासवर्ड आपका जो टूल्स ऐसे ही करता है काम
प्रैक्टिकल एग्जाम होता है ईजी पीटी उसमें
क्या है कि आपके पास वल्नरेबल मशीन है ठीक
है और आपको क्या करना है इंटरनेट एक्सेस
नहीं है मतलब कहने का मतलब जिस मशीन में
आप एग्जाम दोगे उसमें इंटरनेट एक्सेस नहीं
है लेकिन आप अपने लैपटॉप से एग्जाम दोगे
तो आपको छूट है पूरी कि आप क्या कर सकते
हो
google3 टेस्टिंग के एग्जाम होते हैं आपको
आपके पास क्या खुद की एक प्री डिफाइंड
अप्रोच होनी चाहिए आप जितनी ज्यादा
प्रैक्टिस करोगे उतनी ज्यादा आपके पास
प्री डिफाइंड अप्रोच होगी और मिनिम टू
मिनिमम आप हाईलाइट करके रखो कि मुझे इस
टाप प ये टूल यूज करना है सारे टूल यूज
करने की जरूरत नहीं होती मैं मैक्सिमम
टूल्स मैं आपको बता रहा हूं जो कॉमनली यूज
किए जाते हैं अप्रोच मैं आपको बता दूंगा
सिंपली आपको सीटीएफ से प्रैक्टिस करनी है
और फिर आपको एग्जाम अटेम्प्ट्स करने हैं
ओके एक चीज सोचिए कि पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
जोई भी एग्जाम होता है मान के चल व अगर वह
आपको एग्जाम ले इसका मतलब सामने वाली मशीन
बल है और एक और पॉजिटिव पॉइंट है जीजी पटी
के केस में आप मेटा स्लोट कितनी बार भी
यूज कर सकते हो पूरा एग्जाम भी आप मेटा
स्लोट के थ्रू दे सकते हो मतलब क्या है कि
वैसे 24 आवर्स का एग्जाम है व आप घंटों
में खत्म कर दोगे विद द हेल्प ऑफ मेटा
स्ड अभय कितना टाइम लेगा इट विल टेक टाइम
तो कितने लोग साथ में मेरा काम कर रहे हैं
कितने लोग
सब बराबर आना चाहिए विंडोज
काली लिनक्स क्यों चलाने एक काली नक्स को
सिंपली डिलीट कर
दो एक काली लिनक्स को डिलीट कर
दीजिए आप एक काम करो अभी आज हम सेशन को
यहीं पर ओवर करेंगे और आपका प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन एक और बच जाएगा इससे रिलेटेड क्योंकि
अभी हम क्या है बीच में है अभी हमारे पास
क्या है कि जब यहां पर हम सक्सेसफुली
क्रेडेंशियल मिल जाएंगे तो आपको कुछ
स्क्रिप्ट्स मैं आपको बता दूंगा कि
कौन-कौन सी स्क्रिप्ट यूज किया जाती है
उसके बाद सांबा जो आपका बचता है सामा समा
पे एन्यूमरेशन करके दिखाना है सबको
बताओ सेम है सांबा में जो मेटा स्ट यूज
करने वाले हो सेम सेम सारी सारे के एसएमबी
वर्जन एसएमबी यूजर्स इसी तरीके से सांबा
में भी आप क्या कर सकते हो बलड फोर्स अटैक
ट्राई कर सकते हो इसी तरीके से सेम तरीके
ड फ अटैक ट्राई कर सकते हो साबा में भी
सेम
है नहीं शुभम आई विल टीच यू विंडोज पर
कैसे पन टेस्टिंग करनी है हार्ड नहीं है
आपको विंडोज का पहले मैं फंडामेंटल
सिखाऊंगा उसके बाद विंडोज के ऊपर
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग सिखाऊंगा डोंट वरी
एटलीस्ट 8 टू 10 लैब्स हम सॉल्व करेंगे जो
आपको आईडिया दे रहा हूं विंडोज के ऊपर
सीटीएफ लैब्स उसके अंदर आपके पास अप्रोच
होगी टूल्स होंगे आपको दिखाऊंगा कि कैसे
पिटिंग भी आपको बता दूंगा मैं हल्का
फुल्का और आपको दिखा दूंगा कि आपको रूट
एक्सेस तक कैसे जाना है या कैसे अगर आपको
लो लेवल एक्सेस मिलता तो हाई लेवल में
कैसे कन्वर्ट करना आ
तो आपने कंप्यूटर साइंस सीएससी अभी
कंप्लीट किया तो भैया आपको एक सर्टिफिकेशन
चाहिए आपको एटलीस्ट कंपनिया वैसे तो आप
ट्राई करोगे तो बहुत हार्डली क्योंकि आजकल
क्या ना अगर पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग जॉब
चाहिए आपको साइबर सिक्योरिटी के अंदर तो
वह ओनली आपकी डिग्री के बेस पर आजकल नहीं
दे रही सच बात यही है आप लोगों को
सर्टिफिकेशंस करने ही
होंगे बहुत सारी कंपनियां कोई सिक्योरिटी
प्लस सर्टिफिकेट बोलती है साथ में सीच
बोलती है या ईजी पीटी बोलती है बट मेरी
बात मानोगे तो अगर आपके पास नॉलेज होनी
चाहिए आपके पास डिग्री होनी चाहिए
और आपके पास कुछ सर्टिफिकेट हम दे रहे हैं
उसके बाद आपके पास स्किल के साथ-साथ फिर
आप क्या कर लो ईजी पीटी कर लो कोई जो एक
पॉपुलर सर्टिफिकेट अगर आपको करना है तो वह
कर
लीजिए अदर वाइज आने वाले टाइम में अगर
आपके पास टाइम है तब तक अग जॉब नहीं मिलती
आने वाले टाइम में हमारा मास्टर
सर्टिफिकेट कर लेना उसको हम कप कंपनी के
साथ अप्रोच करने वाले हैं कंपनी उस परे
एग्री करेंगे कर जाएंगी तो हम फिर वह
हमारा ऑफिशियल सर्टिफिकेट हो जाएगा पूरा
आप उसको कहीं पर भी यूज कर सकते
हो अब लिंक दिन पर जाइए देखिए मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं तब तक यह चलता
रहेगा अब इट विल टेक टाइम बहुत टाइम लेगा
देखो मैं आपको लिंक दिन पर लेकर जाता हूं
तब तक यह रही मेरी एक लिंक दिन प्रोफाइल य
देखो माय नेटवर्क में जाता हूं मैं अभी
मेरे को पास किसी ने रिक्वेस्ट भेजिए अभी
देखो अभी मैं यहां पर कुछ नहीं है जॉब में
जाता हूं जॉब में मैंने क्या किया अब लिंक
दिन इतना स्मार्ट है कि आपने देखो बग
हंटिंग हैंड्स न ट्रेनिंग कोर्स विद
इंटर्नशिप सर्टिफिकेट अभी यहां पर है नहीं
तो मेरे को बारबार क्या है कि पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग से रिलेटेड व मेरे को दे देखो यह
रही पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग रिमोट ज 108 ने 8
है और पेनिट्रेशन रिट 405 टोटल देखो अलर्ट
ऑन इंडिया देखिए य रही फ्रीलांस सीध
स्पीकिंग इंटरनेट एसोसिएशन यह रहा अप्लाई
करना कितने अप्लाई कर चुके सिक्स पीपल
क्लिक अप्लाई एंड यह र इनके अबाउट द जॉब
यह रहा अब लिंक दिन इसके लिए सबके लिए
यहां पर देखो फाइव कं आपके पास क्या क्या
होना चाहिए ओनरशिप रेगुलर स्मार्टफोन वो
व्ट एवर व्ट एवर जीमल प्राइमरी अकाउंट व्ट
एवर ट आपके ये आप सब कुछ बता रहा य उसके
बाद यह
रही रिस्पांसिबिलिटी क्या स्किल चाहिए
आपके पास देखो यह क्या बोल रहा है शुड हैव
ए स्ट्रांग अंडरस्टैंडिंग द एनर्जीम टास्क
बिल्ड ऑयल गैस पावर कमटी अब यह क्या है और
कुछ है फॉर्मर डेवलपमेंट अभी क्या क्या
किस च किस के लिए पोस्ट मांग रहे हो
डिपेंड करता है ना आपके अब जैसे अभी स
सिस्टम इंजीनियर सिस्टम इंजीनियर अलग है
अभी स्प्लंक यह रहा अभी सीच ट्रेनर मांग
रहे हैं यह तो यह अलग ही है साइबर
सिक्योरिटी इंटर्न इंटर्न यह देखो यह रहा
टू गेट टाइमली अपडेट न जॉब्स ओपनिंग सोन
सो एज देखो रिस्पांसिबिलिटी एस्ट एंड
मॉनिटरिंग एनालाइजिंग सिक्योरिटी इवेंट्स
एसआई एम आना चाहिए पार्टिसिपेट वनटी
असेसमेंट पर्ट एक्टिविटीज और सपोर्ट
इंसीडेंट रिस्पांस एफर्ट अभी देखो कितनी
चीजें मांग रहे हैं ये सारी चीज आपके पास
होनी चाहिए मैंडेटरी रिक्वायरमेंट करेंटली
एनरोल्ड इन डिप्लोमा डिग्री कंप्यूटर
साइंस इनफॉर्म सिक्योरिटी एंड स्ट्रांग
इंटरेस्ट इन सर्वे सिक्योरिटी एंड डिजायर
लर्न एंड डेवलप ए न्यू स्किल इन द फील्ड
बेसिक अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ नेटवर्किंग कंसेट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कॉमन साइबर सिक्योरिटी
प्रिंसिपल्स
फैमिल विद द सिक्योरिटी टूल्स टेक्नोलॉजी
फायरवॉल एंटीवा सॉफ्टवेयर इंट डिटेक्शन
सिस्टम इज प्लस ओके अभी देखो प्रेफर्ड
रिक्वायर लिख दिया कम सिक्योरिटी प्लस
सीएस लिख दिया अब ये किसी काम का नहीं है
इससे ज्यादा ईजी पीटी लिखो सिक्योरिटी
प्लस बिल्कुल बेसिक सर्टिफिकेशन नॉट
रिक्वायर्ड इसके जगह हमारा सर्टिफिकेशन
लगा देना आप ओके अ य रहा नाउ दि आर द
बेनिफिट्स अभी इंटर्न है
देखो दे लॉट ऑफ अपॉर्चुनिटी अवेलेबल इन द
अ यहां पर देखो पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर
यह रही ये रही की रिस्पांसिबिलिटी
प्रेफर्ड क्वालिफिकेशन लिखी हुई है देखो
सीच सीपीटी सीएसपी जो भी व्हाट एवर इ लिखा
हुआ
है पता चल गया सबको
अभी के लिए हम क्या करेंगे सेशन को ओवर
करेंगे क्योंकि इट विल टेक टाइम मे बी लॉट
ऑफ टाइम्स अभी तक कुछ भी ग्रीन हुआ नहीं
क्या और एक ब हमने भी बीच में छोड़ दिया
था इट विल टेक लॉट ऑफ टाइम
तो जो कंटिन्यू सेशन हम नेक्स्ट सेशन में
करेंगे फिर
ओके य स आप लगा सकते
हो य काम कर दो आप लोगों को टास्क दे दूं
मैं
कौन-कौन से कुछ भारतवज आपने सर्टिफिकेट
किए
बताइए मल्टीपल टाइम कर चुके हो कौन-कौन से
सर्टिफिकेट किए आपने मल्टीपल टाइम्स
सीसीटी सीच और डेफ
के अवेलेबल
कोर्सेस तो यट प अवेलेबल कोर्सेस आपके
फंडामेंटल क्लियर करते ना भाई उसके अलावा
अभी हमने यह निकाला है यह देखो देखो देखो
देखो देखो यह मिल गया
प्लस यह कॉमिनेशन मिल गया एक प्लस ग्रीन
ग्रीन ग्रीन देखो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर और
ग्रेंट देखो ट फोस सक्सेस हो गया
हमारा तो वांटेड सबसे पहले इसी कोर्स को
पढ़िए
यह देखो देखो सक्सेसफुली वी गोट सक्सेस ये
रहा
सक्सेस हमने सक्सेसफुली ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक
कते एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर नेम और वे ग्रेंट
पासवर्ड
है
ओके एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एंड वि ग्रंट पता पता
चल गया अभी
देखो सबको पता चला गया बताइए सबको पता
चला यह रहा सक्सेस स्क्रीनशॉट आप ले सकते
हो यह रहे यह रहा यह रहा यह
रहा तो हमारे पास यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड हो
गया है नेक्स्ट क्लास हमें कंटिन्यू
करेंगे अभ इस बल फोस को कंट्रोल सी कर
देता हूं ओके इसको रोक देता हूं इट विल
टेक टाइम हमारे पास यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड
हो गया सक्सेसफुली हमें मिल गया इसके बाद
मैं आपको कंटिन्यू सिखाऊंगा कि अब मेरे
पास यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड है तो यूजर्स
यूजर्स की इंफॉर्मेशन शेयर की इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करेंगे देन सांबा
उसके ऊपर एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म करेंगे
ऑटोमेशन और वो एसएमबी मैप एसएमबी मैप के
बारे में थोड़ा सा बताऊंगा एक दो टूल्स और
के बारे में बताऊंगा नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम
इसको खत्म कर देंगे ओके दिस इ द पार्ट वन
ऑफ द एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन पार्ट टू और
करेंगे एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन का देन उसके बाद
हम फिनिश कर देंगे ओके
तो नेक्स्ट सेशन हम लेंगे डे आफ्टर टुमारो
एक दिन छोड़ के एक दिन अभी मैं सेशन प्लान
कर रहा हूं आप लोगों के लिए तो नेक्स्ट
सेक्शन विल बी अवर डे आफ्टर टुमारो तो अगर
आपका कोई भी डाउट है रिलेटेड टू द क्लास
तो आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हैं आपको मैंने लिंक
दिन और
बताइए तो सेशन को आज मैं चाहता था कि
एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन आज हमारा कंप्लीट हो
जाए बट अनफॉर्चूनेटली बीच में हमारे 10 टू
15 मिनट जो हमारे खराब हुए हैं तो उसकी
वजह से क्या
हुआ थोड़ा सा हमारा क्या 10 15 मिनट में
मैं आपका कवर करवा देता कुछ चीजें लेकिन
डोंट वरी एसएमबी एमरे पार्ट टू भी हम
करेंगे उसके बाद
देन पार्ट टू करने के बाद एफटीपी
एन्यूमरेशन पर जाएंगे
ओके मेरी लिंक दिन आईडी यार ये है आप
डायरेक्टली य सर्च कर लीजिए ना य रहा मैं
लिंक देने पर यह सर्च मार लो आप यह रहा एस
एम एसएम आपको आ
जाएगा स्क्रीनशॉट ले लो
ओके किसी का और डाउट ओके सर आई एम 19 ईयर
ओल्ड बट आई एम इन द 10थ फ्रॉम वेर आई कैन
तो तो आप एक काम करो अभी साथ के साथ जो भी
कोर्सेस चल रहे हैं जैसे कि अभी य डीसी
जीस ये अपना डीई एच ई चल रहा है हमारा इस
कोर्स को फिनिश कीजिए और साथ साथ अपने
पढ़ाई पर ध्यान दीजिए 12थ कंप्लीट कीजिए
देन डिग्री में एंटर कीजिए और तब तक साथ
के साथ जो भी हमारे कोर्सेस हैं पेड
कोर्सेस या फ्री कोर्सेस है सबको करते रहे
आपके पास एक जब आप डिग्री कंप्लीट करोगे
आपके पास एक गुड अमाउंट ऑफ नॉलेज होगी
आपके पास और तब आप जवाइन कर सकते हो आपके
पास बहुत कुछ होगा उस उस टाइम
पर तो सेशन को एंड करें